avant de voir son tacle on va résumer un
peu l'histoire puisque rappelez vous en
avril dernier mathieu oui vous en vous
en étiez pris aille à nakamura la
qualifiant de madonna de banlieue je me
rappelle très bien ça m'avait
extrêmement choquée a bon c'était dans
tpm peut regarder et elles vous encore
remis une petite couche mois aujourd'hui
en ce 12 novembre
mais est-ce qu'on va fêter
l'anniversaire d'un tweet voilà regard
sur leur faim donc d'après vous qui se
prend telle qu'elle était vexé qui se
trompe sur son nom je la comprends
parfaitement mais ensuite il a présenté
ses excuses quand là bas sur un twitter
devant tout le monde et j'ai repris
aussi à l'antenne et maintenant madame
attend qu'elle l'appelle veut pas être
utile de macron aussi pour être sûr
qu'on l'appelle et que tout va bien moi
moi le battre et du mythique rond sur
internet et bas madame alia nakamura
j'attends vos excuses alors qui est tout
à fait différent pour madonna ça va donc
et bien si justement aujourd'hui surtout
novembre on fête l'anniversaire d'un
tweet à magnifique 8,2 yadaya nakamura
qui vous traité de petit con mathieu il
ya pile un petit con matthieu delormeau
respecter les gens merde alors c'est
vrai que vous aimez pas tous les deux
bien aller à vous a répondu aujourd'hui
en vous glissant tita qu'à la partager
sur son compte twitter une vidéo publiée
quelques heures plus tôt où l'on voit
madonna et ses danseurs sont blancs
c'est sur son titre djadja regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et et alain nakamura
elle est assez sympathique el hani
madonna qui sent bien sur la base de
dattes beaulieu se sent pas prêt de noël
et oman a été touché j'ai par exemple
parce que c'est votre ami se sont que le
jeudi de reprendre une offre combinant
mais à l'écrit ne répondait mais l'aston
visage qu'on fasse un budget dit une
fois que l avait beaucoup de talent et
ça c'est vrai et que effala c'est une
fille car non ah c'est sûr maintenant ce
qui est dommage c'est qu'il a une très
mauvaise réputation et c'est vrai voilà
malheureusement qui a dit ça la scala
gianni cause qu'il avait couché son
nikos était le cas et l'appareil c'est
mignon ce qu'elle fait mais si vraiment
sur les danseurs de madonna c'est pas
elle de poster ça a un côté les danseurs
de madonna les mois sur huitième degré 3
qui connaît vraiment les artistes ah oui
c'est vrai nous tellement c'est comme si
moi je montrais plein d'artistes de long
est tous en train de parler de moi c'est
pas elle demeure à jamais c'est dommage
quand on a autant de talent d'avoir
autant une raison
elle est fière d'elle a raison elle est
sympa c'est maradona capot c'est ça
l'art aux tweets et c'est bien oui aya
nakamura est l'une des artistes les
françaises les plus primés à l'étranger
aux états unis etc et sur netflix ya la
saison de la série qui est sortie et
tout de suite la semaine c'est un
pendant 7 et 10 la première scène c'est
une fête etc
et qu'est ce qu'ils foutent les jeunes
espagnols à cette fête aya nakamura elle
est partout c'est normal c'est normal
qu'elle met en avant sa mort la veille
que c'est défendre mon vol à la scierie
allez-y
non juste pour métier c'est dommage que
la chanson une des chanteuses les plus
connus à l'étranger où comprennent pas
un mot quand tu es en france où qu'ils
soient je comprends est usiné
la pitié donc ça je le comprends pas
alors me dit papa j'aimerais 100 ans
je suis jolie n'ont arrêté il ya des
gens qui pensent comme moi ma mère m'a
dit mais ça veut dire quoi pompiers dont
elle parle elle pas le droit de parler
au nom langage de son sort elle va
partir avec toi mais après c'est
compliqué dans une chose percée mais
arrêtons très bien le ballon jab année
les six ans mais c'est nul de dire ça et
valoir ses proches et ma seule pensée
j'ai enlevé mes chaussons une chanteuse
mais qu'on pense aux cellules saines
france chacun son style
il ya des gens qui vont dire moi j'aime
pas les paroles d'un compenseront dire
ça et voulait dernier à celle quand vous
avez dit ceux qui la connaissent pas
sont des nuls à l'épée reconnu par dont
cyril c'est votre ami vous la connaissez
ton mieux pour vous il ya des gens qui
la connaissent pas elle n'était pas
connue il ya un an hery on sait que tu
n'as que les relations étaient bonnes et
la tête pour rien laisser aller c'est
laisser les artistes car leur travail
elle a un énorme succès au contraire là
une très grande personnalité et c'est ça
que j'aime au moment des artistes comme
elle qui ont une personnalité comme ça
alors justement elle a un style avec son
langage mois voilà je kiffe parce que
voilà tata ont été dix mois mais les
enfants qu'ils faillent anaqua mois moi
je vous le dis tous mes potes kifaya n'a
qu'à moi je suis désolé voilà donc un
acquis qui fait vous qui fait pas chacun
son choix mais en tout cas il ya
nakamura en a besoin d'artistes oreilles
parce qu'elle est une vraie personnalité
moi j'en peux plus des artistes plat qui
dit rien c'est comme angel on a besoin
d'angel aussi en ce moment il ya des
artistes voilà je vous dis qu'ils
joueront un grand talent qui ont plus
une personnalité on va pas s'en plaindre